so we will again do some of the coding
and uh
it is going to take a while for the
coding to
load and some of the packages to install
so it is okay if you are not able to
follow up and you can get the recording
and then
do some more
work with some more coding
in
referring to the recording but before
that i need to know how many of you yeah
exactly thank you ng and how many of you
have good expertise or decent expertise
in r and uh python okay beginner
excellent
so if you are comfortable if you are a
newbie or
if you know only to open up r or
python's environment and then you want
use a couple of
lines of codes to maybe uh
maybe
quickly plot a plot or maybe just load a
very small file and yeah basic knowledge
that's perfect
okay
okay that is what we want so i don't
want to start from absolute basic like
what is a variable what is a data frame
so everybody knows what a data frame is
and everybody knows what an array or a
matrix is so that is what we want to
understand
so okay we are going to use uh
the environment that that we are happy
to explore
with google collaborate your google
collab uh python notebook called uh
notebooks so this is a shareable link
environment which will run in python and
also in ours
programming a tool or rs programming
tool so you can access this you can have
your own copy of this when if you have
your google link or google
account
set up
so if you have not set it up quickly you
can do this by uh typing collab dot
yeah call yeah wait i
hope shares the code on the chat yeah we
will share the codes that we are going
to explore today and yeah so um
wait a second let me give the link where
if you type
collab dot
t o
and then you can go to uh collabs
environment and for example
this is what you will see
and
and this will run both python and rs
environment even though it is
the extension shows that it is
interactive python network so right now
it is simply a python notebook and you
can actually open up a new notebook from
the here because you cannot say what
they name it as or what you get as a
scratch pad so scratch pad you cannot
save the course that is presented to the
scratchback
or you can save a copy that so open a
new environment so that it we enable the
automatic saving
tool so everybody start working along
with me
so we need to do this before even
starting to get a get an idea of what we
are going to discuss today because some
of the packages that we need to use will
take long time to install so that we can
manage our time effectively by
running through these
installations before even starting to
use this notebook so are you here
if everybody here everybody can see
untitled zero dot ipy and b
and this is a python notebook and how do
i know because i opened it and if you
are unsure of whether you are using a
collaboratory notebook in python or in
rs environment
you can go to runtime the menu runtime
and then you can come all the way to
change runtime type and then if you do
not see any option just below the
notebook settings or just above the
hardware accelerator to change to python
or r then this is a python's notebook so
you cannot run r code in this this is a
specific python's notebook so this is
fine we don't need to install anything
in python's notebook but
if you instead of using this if you use
the another link like
colab.2r
right it can be lowercase or uppercase
it does not matter
if you
do this and enter
and you can do this
collab dot 2 r
and we are going to look at an exactly
identical environment right
and we will explore what to do and how
to run and what is the what are the
couple of settings that you need to uh
make sure that it is presentable and etc
so how are we going to run this
while we are exploring some of the codes
so in this environment uh this i uh
started it by uh typing collab dot uo
dot slash art so i know that it is a it
is an arts environment but if you are
unsure landing up in someone else's
collab and etc you can find out by
opening run time again and then
using the option change run time type so
in this change run time type you have an
option
that tells this runtime type can be
changed from r to python right so if you
have that option and if you have that
option r enabled then it is an r it is a
uh
collab notebook under rs environment so
that's so
you will know this
okay so we can still cancel a save it
does not matter
we get out of this so what is the power
of using such a
collapse environment i mean one of the
important uh
advantages for example you can see
at some of the copy of collab notebook
so you can
write some codes and get an output right
below that and such a level of
linking or linking the output to a
specific code is not very easy in any
other
development environment or tool that you
are going to use even in our studio
which uh which i have been using or
which many people will be using for ours
environment you will have something like
this where
you have a place where you can type the
course and where you have a place where
you can execute the codes and interact
with our console and then when we have a
separate
section where your plots is going to be
displayed i have not loaded any plot so
it is not loading up anything but this
is where your plots are going to display
and
at any specific time you can view only
one of the plots and
you have to go back and forth to
check previous plot and the next part so
um there are specific advantages in
using collab like uh setup and people
are are actually using call lab like
setup in local computer also like
jupiter notebook and etc and that will
help you
in analysis like this you can
compare and contrast the output write
one below the other and check what is
the specific code that makes this
type of
plot so that you can
come back to the code and relate and
another big advantage is
the shared ability of such notebooks or
such a setup so if you click on share
and you can share this notebook with
many people you can see that this is a
very popular notebook and this has been
shared already with many people of my
collaborators and co-workers
not in this case because i opened it
this is a copy of this so you do not see
it so you can add people and add groups
here and share it with others
so that you can
check
between the versions and between the
execution of the code along
with your friends and collaborators and
your supervisors and co-workers and etc
and
you don't have to add everybody here you
can just make it uh make the access
general access as anybody can access
with the link and copy the link and then
share it with people like you and then
so that anybody who opens this notebook
can get access to uh the codes and the
outputs so this is this shareability is
is
is
very very important uh
advantage of google collab so you know
for follow-ups uh
advantage so let's go back again to your
uh
our collab so everybody has opened your
r collab here
so if you everybody has opened up your
our collab
i want you to
run these
and then forget about that colab we will
come back to this collab when it is uh
until uh until the time that we are here
then it would have completed our
installation so how how would you run
this this is my r collapse and then you
copy it and
you open up a code block from here right
if you see something like this and then
you open up a new code block by clicking
insert a code cell below so you press
and then inside this you can just type
or paste so this is what i want
everybody to type or paste inside there
our
notebook
and if you do that and then
start this
install command or insta start this
execute this code
option then you will see it see some
output and see it installing all the
packages one by one so
let's let everybody start so i'm not
going to do it one more time because i
have already done it
and let me know is is your installation
running smoothly so one you just have to
start it and it will install if you get
an error
right like this for example
if you get an error like
let it run it will actually initialize
before running so connect and initialize
before running so if you get an error
like invalid syntax or install install
option not found then that would mean
you are actually running this code uh
this is an r code you are running this r
code in python synthetic so make sure
that you are running it under arts
environment is everybody there
can i see uh some responses
sir how to run this uh i have uh
inserted or pasted it and press this
triangle
okay okay so
it will start running so you will see it
working out and you'll see some output
some
option and output here
something like this installing package
and etcetera etcetera okay
okay we will let it install it's going
to take a while to install pseudo and
the umap and
cls environment which we will use
extensively and yeah
while it is running you will see that
the code takes a red
or a gray
color code and it will show you that it
is ready to be uh used in in this kind
of color coding yellow or yellow
challenge particles so let's just
start with
okay perfect so everybody it is working
so um
that is the case let me clean up some of
these things
[Music]
so we let this run and then we will come
back to this later
leave that's okay and i also don't want
this
okay so we'll come back to this uh in a
while so what are we going to learn so
we saw yesterday uh an excellent uh
demos demonstration session from raja
and also an overview of
what you will what you can do and what
are the analysis methods that you can do
and what you can learn from single cell
rna analysis and how it compares
generally to bulk solar and analysis in
uh
in the second session so today i'm going
to introduce you to another
learning resources in which we have
taken up a
publication which focuses on
understanding the heterogeneity of
non-small cell lung carcinoma and using
single-celled analysis of single-cell
data methods single-cell profiling
methods so we will explore what this
specific publication actually deals with
and
what we can learn from this publication
and what are the analysis that we can
actually perform from a data that is
publicly available partially publicly
available
from this so
you will learn
what are the
kind of analysis that you can perform
using uh python's environment and what
other analysis methods that you can
actually you
perform using our
environment are very well known and a
popular single cell analysis package c
ray
and there are advantages of using
analysis options
inside surat's
bracket or students package or students
[Music]
module
there are also several other advantages
of using uh
similar analysis methods outside of
civics packages and outside of students
models so we will also explore those
methods today
yeah so
let's
so what do we have in this specific uh
lesson so we start with in the lesson
one it starts with introducing you
towards different types of lung cancer
and
that will actually tell you
why
performing such study is extremely
important and
just like any other carcinoma or any
other tumor lung cancer also
appreciably heterogeneous right and
depending upon where it occurs the type
of lung cancer can vary and the effect
of their cancer can also vary and there
are some popular or
most abundant
lung cancers that you can see and you
will also see several
introduction and
overview about
some of the risk factors some of the
recent treatments and trends uh sinta
clement if you are getting syntax editor
then i think you are actually running
the install uh packages in python's
environment please start another collab
with collab dot 2
r
and then after that if you copy and
paste you will not get a syntax effect
so yeah so uh
you you go through this and you will get
lot of information about
setting up generally the importance of
studying uh heterogeneity in lung cancer
to understand some of the heterogeneity
and some
options and what what do you see
is you will have tumor this
generally very heterogeneous uh
tissue right
you will get a very uh good overview
from from our resources if you go back
to the course and go to the second
lesson
and
partially
people have tried to study this humor
heterogeneity from from different
methods like uh for example let's
take
i'm looking for a picture
in the associated resources i think it's
it's in lesson one only i forgot
so uh
that should actually help you
very low
yes okay exactly so this is just a
cartoon of how many different types of
cells that one can identify or one can
actually find in a regular tumor right
this is what we actually tell in terms
of tumor micro environment and you many
of you might have gotten some
introduction or at least heard of this
term tumor micro environment and
even before the advent or even before
the extensive use of single cell arnatic
analysis to study and to understand this
tumor heterogeneity people have been
trying to mimic or trying to um
do the same with the bulk rnac
technology by visually picking and
collecting samples from different
portions of these tumor micro
environment right and
and you can see examples of such studies
all over the uh all over the research
and all over the
databases and repositories also
that can also be done and
even
in spite of those
efforts we have to uh remember
that uh
tumor is extremely highly heterogeneous
environment and
sometimes the advantages of single cell
profiling just over uh overtakes
the resolution overtakes
some of the other um
analysis options that balsa rna gives us
so we we again will have some
complexities associated with this and
this
this publication is an excellent example
of what you can achieve from
such
such studies so let us let me zoom in
here this is one of the one of their
important results that they observe
so they identify something like very
close to
nine different uh
subtypes 11 major cell subtypes from 42
patients that they obtain the samples
from so
this is
a projection
umap projection representation of how
different cell
tissue types or different tumor tissue
types
or tissue types from this micro
environment can be represented in the
umap projection of their
expression data and again this is how
all the 42 patients will actually
compare in the same
representation so you will get a good
idea about some of the discussion that
we had yesterday right the clustering or
identification of different cell types
is actually done in the original space
but this sense this is just a
representation you will see
some overlaps which should not be
mistaken into um
actual overlaps between the cell types
or actual overlap between the data and
you can see the percentage of different
tissue types populating different
patient and we can see how
different these patients are depending
upon their composition of these cell
types these are prominent
results that this publication actually
achieves and in addition to that they
also
identify some new cell types and they
also find
markers
gene markers for
novel cell types and cell identification
using this single cell profiling method
so these these are all extremely
important results and very useful
results that we have to
discuss and interested people can go and
read this paper this is excellent
so how to access this data so um we also
have uh
in the second lesson we also have
information on
what is the data available and how to
access the data and what is that we are
going to take consider and what is a
project setup that we have actually uh
set out to
uh work with
in this
data so the overall case study can be
downloaded from this gene expression
omnibus dataset and
this is the accession id you can
actually go to this by just clicking
this link which you will get this link
so
here
immediately you see that in in overall
design say that
the raw data or the fastq files data of
each and every one of these 42 samples
is not available because of patient
privacy concepts so
so sometimes we are not we will not get
this but in such cases we will get
access to
their normalized data or
processed data so that's what we are
going to get so this study includes 42
patients 42 samples and
and
you will see the same
for each one of these patients if you
click this id you will go to
their expression table which you can
download so this is what we will be
accessing right
so we cannot actually uh or we can do it
but uh if we want to perform some
analysis on all the 42 patients we will
need more resources and so we restrict
ourselves in this case for uh
demonstration purposes to five of these
samples
and these
yeah and
come down here yes
oh what is this
okay uh
let's go back i think it's in the third
uh third lesson so we restrict our study
to five of these uh patients uh
so that we can swiftly perform this
analysis and and also study and also see
if
if the kind of
tumor heterogeneity that the original
publication actually achieves in
in using all the 42 samples can be
can be reflected on or can be found from
the uh
from these five samples alone so we
selected randomly selected uh samples of
two uh carcinoma type one one is a small
squamous cell and the other one is
adenocarcinoma three samples in one and
two samples of the other so that
we can try to see if
if we also observe similar
dispersion of different cell types and
what are the cell types that that we can
identify ah
and and how different uh are our
markers and cell type
annotation to the original publication
so that so that kind of analysis that we
can actually perform by using a subset
of samples so of course
you can select completely different
subset and ah
and identify if
if the comparison is actually valid and
if if we get a similar results to
the original publication or if not so
several several different parameters
actually define how you get to these
results and you will see that uh in a
while so
and you will also see learn to
appreciate the complexity of uh single
cell rna
profiling single cell iron analysis
unlike the
bulk cell counterpart where most of the
work or most of the analysis tools are
very well established and
and it runs like a well oiled machine
like just start an analysis and then you
will get differential gene expression
analysis at the end of it if your
samples are really very well separated
so that is what we set out to